i remember when you told me that when
you first started dating aaron yeah yeah
and i knew he wrestled i didn't know
[ __ ] about rapping like you ever hear
kurt angle yeah yeah he goes so i'm
dating this girl and i guess i guess her
her uncle was like this big wrestler or
something have you ever him
[Music]
today we have a real american hero an
olympic champion a gold medal winner
1996 olympics in wrestling wwe champion
of the world and um all-around uh
incredible human being and more
importantly than all of that he's uh
he's my uncle-in-law uh kurt angle i'm
grateful that he's here uh i love him
with all my heart and i hope you guys
dig the episode the biggest undeniable
in my life with without a doubt is uh is
my wife you know is is aaron you know
your niece she's the woman of my dreams
and and um i respect her more and more
in any way got a good one
you're right yeah right and and uh and i
will say that you know i think when you
marry into someone's family um
i can you know you hear people there's
like those those age-old adages about
you know i have the [ __ ] in-laws or
you know like
her mom hates me or something you know
but but you love them
you know man i'm just you know and and i
see so much you know the things that i
love most about my wife um you know her
her work ethic her honesty um how tough
she is she was a phenomenal athlete dude
so then like and she when she was at
when she was young she used to wrestle
mark right whoop his butt too and you
said and and mark i mean margaret markey
was his first year he was 28-1 and um
he he won states almost every year and
aaron was kicking his butt and they were
the same weight class yeah they're only
one year apart
uh so aaron would have done extremely
well but back then they didn't have
girls arrested that's right i mean she
and i used to wrestle all the time and
she would beat the [ __ ] and she was
dirty as [ __ ] too she would fish hook me
i definitely want to get into like the
the um
you know the way you grew up and how you
grew up but just tell me a little bit
about uh
you know i i you know i never got to
meet your old man you know um but i i
got to know grandma jackie pretty well
and yeah she's like honestly like one of
my favorite people you know i mean like
everybody's yeah right and so like just
tell me a little bit about your your mom
and your dad and what what kind of
people
my mom and dad growing up um
from the day i remember
uh the one thing that surrounded our
family was sport we all had to be in
sports
didn't matter which sport you were in
uh you had you had to have a sport
that you would excel at and
i wasn't good by any means i was
probably the worst athlete in the family
and i used to cry a lot so if i lost i
was you know
didn't take it very well and eric used
to my older brother used to whip my ass
quite a bit yeah so uh i was more of a
crybaby a [ __ ] i didn't didn't like the
one-on-one sports like the team sport
because it wasn't all
dependent on me
but that bothered me it bothered me so
much that
i um
i wanted to make it that i was
comfortable with a one-on-one sport i
wanted to i wanted to be like my
brothers
so my mother and dad um
they never missed a sporting event that
any of us did
traveled around the world let alone you
know not just locally but my mother went
to every one of my wrestling events um
did your dad play sports
yeah my dad played uh football in the
army and uh
he was pretty good he was a half back
but
um you know when when they had david he
david would excelled extremely well in
football and baseball and basketball and
and then mark came along
he was a second in the family and
uh he was uh he was different mark was
um he's the baddest dude i've ever known
in my entire life
the toughest guy i've ever known in my
entire life
tougher than any other person i've ever
met and
he got in a lot of trouble growing up
and
he just had a he had an anger problem
yep uh you know it caused him to go to
juvenile court uh he went away the
juvenile delinquent center for two years
and that that was for for beating up
them two cops yeah
a
couple
you
cops
in
eighth
in eighth grade he was he was like five
ten one eighty five he was he was uh
he you know 12 13 years old but he was
he was when did you guys know because
you know like i remember for instance
like the day i i proposed to aaron i
don't know if you remember this but
today we were all at your uh grandma i
mean you're all at your mom's uh
apartment
and uh we're all hanging out and i was
talking to you on the couch and these
were still in the days you mark just so
everybody knows that's my that's my my
father-in-law that's it and uh those
were still in the days where i always
kind of gave
mark like a pretty wide berth you know
like as everybody did because i just saw
like around pittsburgh
i would see guys that i would be like
just on site okay that's a that's a
serious guy and they would give mark a
real wide berth you know what i mean so
i just kind of always gave and i
remember i said to you man i i was there
aaron wasn't even in town and i needed
to go to mark to ask for his blessing
and i said to you
you were you were wrestling you were you
you know you i didn't tell you to run
well no i came to you and i was like
kurt man and you're like what are you
you kind of figured it out like what are
you doing here with aaron not here and
you and i didn't really know each other
that well you know and i said like hey
man i'm actually here cause i'm gonna
ask mark if uh if it's okay that i marry
aaron and you're like oh [ __ ] i'm
staying here now man i'm not going
anywhere and you're like good luck buddy
he's like i gotta see this i went over
to mark you know and he was uh to get
baby nico on his on his i love kids
loves i mean to see ya and i mean that's
but i you know i remember i said hey hey
mark you know you think uh you think i
could talk to you for a minute in the in
the um in the hallway he's like
i'm like you think i could talk to you
and and like i asked him like i don't
know if he like couldn't really hear i
mean i i think that that was as scared
as i had ever
been and like you know i remember the
first time i came to pittsburgh guys
were coming up to me saying to me have
you met
have you met her dad yet and i said no
that's why i'm here i'm going to meet
him and they'd say oh i think he might
be the toughest guy in the country and
you know when you hear things like that
you're like come on stories
i mean everyone had so like what like
when did you know
when did everybody know that mark angle
was a different
different breed when he was in high
school
after he got out of juvenile court um i
think he was a junior high school he the
wrestling coach asked him
we need we need to stay out of trouble
and we're going to put you in wrestling
because this is where you can take your
aggression out on other people
and mark did it in the first year he
wrestled he went to state in
pennsylvania yeah and that doesn't
happen yeah that's that's impossible
yeah and um
and while that was occurring
mark garnered the reputation around
pittsburgh
um that he would take on all fighters so
the they would have these fights every
couple weeks where
these people from pittsburgh different
high schools would come to mark and say
i heard about you i want to fight you
and you know everybody talks about this
like like it happened all the time back
then
it didn't this is the this you know
everybody wants to say their brother's
the toughest guy and he used to beat
people up and guys used to come and want
to fight him yeah this is true this is
what happened
and mark never lost he never lost a
fight
but you know he kept getting in trouble
and
uh
so long story short
his senior year he did extremely well
and all these colleges wanted them yeah
and uh they knew he only wrestled two
years and they were like
licking their chops we got to get our
hands on this guy so his grades weren't
good enough to go to college but he went
to junior college
in his first year there he already had a
kid and uh he was married the cindy and
uh he was there he did extremely well at
the nationals that year he made it to
the semis he he got injured so he had to
back out uh but he probably would have
won the junior college nationals
and uh arizona state was ready to give
him a scholarship the next year and to
play football too right
no he wasn't gonna play football no he
wasn't gonna play football but he was he
was he was really good at football yeah
he also tried out for the philadelphia
eagles by the way yeah back in the 70s
uh but mark um
he just did uh he excelled in wrestling
and uh
and you know
winning all these fights and then he
goes to college he ends up getting his
wife pregnant again he has to work now
yeah he can't go to college anymore back
then you couldn't there's no way you're
gonna have a wife and two kids and go to
school yeah and work and wrestle yeah
it's just not gonna happen yeah mark had
to give it up yeah and
when he did that
his efforts went to who do you think
johnny and eric and kurt yeah so now
we're under the mark you know umbrella
yeah and we're doing what he wanted to
do and what's that like
it was tough it was like getting old i
would tell you this
um his son was the best wrestler in our
family by far
um but
mark starred him way too early four
years old by the time he graduated
college he didn't want to do it anymore
being
mark angle's little brother was not easy
but it also
there was a lot of bonuses too what were
the bonuses
knowing how to win knowing how to train
having someone that knows what he's
doing yeah you know
oversee you the whole time you know
it was tough because you know i couldn't
be a kid i i would be literally sleeping
saturday morning and
he would call and say
i put kurt on the phone he called my mom
i'm like what do you want he's like
you're going to a tournament today i'm
not going to a tournament he said yes
you are you're coming with me right now
yeah and i'd have to go and it was like
i don't want to do this you know but
what he did for me
i could never forget
um the thing is i i took it the right
way and i used what he did for me and i
i motivate myself to become better
didn't you tell me that that you at
first did not make the olympic team
yeah i didn't make the olympic team in
92 i was an alternate and i continued to
be an alternate for the world team
because when you don't have the olympics
in 92 96 2000 2004
the years in between you have the world
championships so 92s the olympics 93s
the worlds 94 is the worlds 95's the
world's the 96's olympics again so you
have a world championship every year
yeah including the olympics they're all
world championships so
um i was i was runner-up three years in
a row yeah and i was like i'm not gonna
make the team i can't beat this guy and
there there are two guys that i was
having problems with winning
so i quit and uh i i it really um really
bothered me that i gave it up before i
even
and and that's why you know i don't want
to tell my nephew marky you know why'd
you quit because i understood why he
quit
but why do you why do you quit like what
is what's the voice in your head that
tells you to quit at that point
that tells you just can't do it you
can't do it yeah what what's the reason
what's the purpose of moving on if
you're gonna be second
and i had to learn the hard way that
the second is not that bad so
at least
if i go back and i
i try to make the team and i take second
at least i can say i did it
i i i quit two years before the olympics
and
i wasn't going to go back
and for those six months it bothered the
hell out of me i just kept thinking i'm
gonna regret this i at least gotta see
it through
so i went back a lot more motivated and
i
the next two years i i i can't believe
this myself because
i won the worlds in 95 i made the world
team won the worlds made the olympic
team won the olympics those two years
that i was going to give up were the two
biggest years of my life
and do you think that there's something
specific that happened inside of you
though did you did you take some
pressure off of yourself was it was it a
different mindset was it
what was different about those two years
well you know i i always it was always
in the back of my head what if i would
what if i would have tried football
because i was an extremely great
football player in high school and
i was an all-state full-back linebacker
and
i thought
you know the steelers came to me with
interest in 1994 and bill cower met with
me and i try out for the steelers
and
i think that's what what broke the
camel's back i trained for it got ready
for it didn't make it
and
yeah yeah it was more of a combine yeah
um
uh the reason i didn't make it is um i
just wasn't fast enough i ran a 4-7 in
that trial yeah yeah i was running four
sixes but um you know that i had a not a
great run but i was i was doing the
patterns uh pass patterns catching the
ball very well but knowing that i tried
that and i did make it i think that's
what
brought me back to wrestling what's the
state of pittsburgh these days well i i
love pittsburgh i love my hometown and
you know that's where my family is
that's where most of my family and my
wife's family is but um
we we want to move we want to either
move out to california or to florida
just to get into warm weather yes you
know i'm 51 years old
i've been wrestling my whole life and my
body you know yeah uh the winters can be
a little yeah rough so yeah i'd prefer
to be somewhere a little warmer do you
feel like the city's changed or do you
feed is one of the things you love about
it that it stays the same like what i i
think a lot of it stays the same i think
it's very traditional
they've been doing better
economy wise but you know overall it's
pittsburgh's pittsburgh you know it's
it's
whatever whatever impression you have
living outside of pittsburgh of
pittsburgh
you're probably right
you know the people are crazy they're
very loyal yeah you know they got that
pittsburgh accent and you know it just
they're very unique and uh and they like
that they like being different yeah so
yeah it's you know if you live in
pittsburgh it's different than the rest
of the other state of pennsylvania
absolutely it's you know it's it's
different but
you know it's it's a steel city that's
how we grew up there was a sports town
and i grew up in that reputation of uh
being proud of being from pittsburgh
and that's probably why i took so much
uh
put so much effort in the sport yes
because everybody there you know sports
were so important especially my family
yeah i mean like i think from the first
times going back there and you know
going to i think i went to a um ken
mcmillan match once i mean
i mean can you describe just sort of
like what wrestling culture is in that
part of the country i'd never seen
anything like the fervor that there is
for wrestling in that in that in that
case pennsylvania is different um they
were always
known very well for the sport of
wrestling and i think um
you know now that they're the number one
state in the country if not the whole
entire world uh in wrestling it has a
lot to do with the structure of
pennsylvania you have to remember
pennsylvania means pens woods
and there's two cities at the end and
the rest is just wood so
you know these people
um you know not a lot of money you know
not not wealthy people more
blue-collared um hard-working people and
um you know with that you know if if
you're a family that's you know a
middle-class family you're not you're
not going to be able to buy football
equipment or or hockey equipment
you're going to get you're going to do
the cheapest sports wrestling all you
need is a pair of wrestling shoes that's
right it's you know it's relatively
cheap same thing with basketball going
out and playing you know
uh but pennsylvania garnered the uh
respect of the whole entire nation
because
year in year out they produce all
americans in college that it's just like
the numbers are ridiculous
yeah i think one year when i was in
college uh the 120 all-americans 72 of
them were from pennsylvania holy [ __ ] in
the whole country yeah so it just shows
the quality of wrestling in the state of
pennsylvania how important is work ethic
and wrestling can is is it more or less
important uh than talent i i think so i
think
you know wrestling is a sport where you
have to kind of figure yourself out um
if you're not a great athlete you got to
figure out a way of how you're going to
win uh you know there are some wrestlers
that are phenomenal athletes they got
great double legs single legs they
attack extremely well there are a lot of
wrestlers that are very defensive and
they're the ones that usually are the
least
gifted athletes
so they they go on defense and they
they react to your offense yeah and
but
i think the whole thing is
figuring yourself out what your style is
going to be are you going to be
aggressive are you going to be passive
are you going to be a funk wrestler or
you can be a technical wrestler what do
you mean by funk wrestler funk is you
know
these guys that do backflips when you
have his leg and he flips over and does
a flip and ends up grabbing your leg and
yeah
just just crazy stunts that you end up
on top yeah
a lot of times you'll see wrestlers do
stuff like that yeah and um
it's trick wrestling yeah and uh it
works you know but
i don't want to say it works a lot but
it it can work if you figure out
how you can do it to your opponent and i
know this you you're not gonna be a
great wrestler unless you put in the
time and i think that's with anything
when i first met aaron and i first was
going to pittsburgh you know look man i
was like a
theater student you know what i mean and
i had to tell mark and she's like what
is he he's an actor he's like hey what's
up sean kerrigan hey come over here how
are you doing what's up man [ __ ] i
didn't even know you were here dude
[ __ ] i just watched the breath
far video yeah
because i met sean i met sean right
right when i met uh like sean me started
hanging out right when aaron and i met
sean you know like i told you he's a pro
fighter wrestled in college
hey get down dude get down
um but i just remember going to
pittsburgh and everybody
you know knows who you are and you're
you're
a god there and and and uh i mean
everyone knows who you are everywhere
but i mean like in pittsburgh but there
was also just something about the angle
family i mean a lot of i'm not the most
popular angle in pittsburgh
market yeah people just call me mark
yeah yeah yeah hey you're mark angle
right now that's my brother yeah i mean
they were all not taught i mean honestly
they weren't talking about you they were
talking about mark
and like what is that i mean so you're
the young you're you're the youngest of
five brothers
like what it and and like i i remember
even at your wedding man like i was at
his wedding and there was like at one
point like all the brothers were like up
on stage together and it's like
dude they're like i mean they're just
[ __ ] monsters you know like it's just
like monsters like what is that like
what is that like badasses yeah yeah i
it it was rough i mean you know
in order to be an angle you had to you
know have that reputation and you know i
i even at one point i wasn't i wasn't
much of a fighter but
you know sixth seventh eighth grade i
was getting fights all the time because
i thought i was supposed to yeah you
know you got this identity that you're
mark engle's little brother and yeah
you're a tough dude yeah until the day i
got my ass kicked by this guy twice my
size and i was like okay man no no more
of this yeah maybe maybe my my goal is
to be a good athlete not a good fighter
so yeah but yeah growing up around mark
and
you know people expected you eric eric
was another oh he was
he was another fighter that uh
uh i don't think he ever lost a fight
either yeah
he was uh he was angry issues but you
know he
he was uh just as almost as tough as
mark pretty close i wouldn't say
nobody's mark's level but yeah
i can't even explain that to anybody
about mark it's funny because you know
when you talk about you know like like
you know sean knows knows mark real well
as as well and i remember when you told
me that when you first started dating
aaron yeah yeah and so i knew he
wrestled i didn't know [ __ ] about ever
hear kurt angle yeah yeah he goes he
goes so i'm dating this girl and i guess
i guess her her uncle is like this big
wrestler or something have you ever
heard of him and i go what's his name
he's like kurt i go you're dating kurt
angle's denise
i was like man
you better you better keep your things
hydrated
man that's a tough family right there
man yeah yeah has wrestling culture in
pennsylvania change because of ufc are
more kids getting into mma or more i i
wouldn't say more kids but um
uh i think that uh
you're gonna see
you're gonna see even more wrestlers
go into mma ufc you you know yeah yeah
it's it it's such a great sport to
parlay into mma uh it's a great base to
have and
you know i i i know that
uh this gives these kids hope of a
professional future that they could have
that boxers only had
uh you know
wrestling is uh not a revenue sport so
you know it's uh pretty cool that now
they have the choice of ufc bellator
even wwe which is not wrestling but you
know it's sports entertainment but
it gives these guys somewhere else to go
after college yep and it gives them hope
of
you know i could be a ufc champion
someday or i could fight in the ufc and
you know after college so
uh we didn't have that back then yeah
the olympics were our pros and that was
it yeah yeah guys used to talk about
that yeah you know there's where you go
yeah there's no sport for us after
college and and then u.s they tried a
pro league and wrestling it didn't work
and just uh why do you think that that
doesn't work
because i mean you watch the ncaa it's
great it means yeah they get a good
turnout i don't know uh
i just don't think it's uh considered a
mainstream sport in america yeah uh
worldwide it's competitive as hell yeah
so it's
we the crazy thing is as as
unmainstream as it is here don't get me
wrong every you know almost every high
school and college you know have some
form of wrestling program but yeah um
it's just uh there's not
you know it's never been considered a an
an american sport you know it's and and
so with that when you you know you you
reach like the pinnacle of all pinnacles
and then
how uh how how did how did your brothers
how did the family respond to the the
choice to go to the w crazy thing of wwe
yeah
uh
they weren't they weren't that happy at
first but you know growing up um i never
watched wwe
i knew
before i signed in 1998
i knew who hulk hogan was
macho man because he had a slim jim
commercial
i literally didn't watch wrestling at
all the only wrestler i really knew was
bruno san martino because he's from
pittsburgh yeah and um i was always told
don't watch that crap that's fake you're
real
my coaches would tell me that my
brothers would tell me that so i never
watched and uh
um you know when i decide to go into it
they're like are you kidding me yeah
how'd that come about
well vince mcmahon called me and said
we'd like to offer you a contract and
you know
uh would you like to come up and we'll
talk so that that's how it started and
like was it always to be
was it always to be kurt angle the
olympic hit like did you guys come up
with i think so i think vince had a an
idea in his head that uh
he um he tried this with the rock uh
when he started and uh it backfired on
him so he wanted he knew it would
backfire on me
but uh i thought he was wrong i didn't
think i was gonna be a bad guy yeah how
does that go medalist you know
um people i love this guy he's a hero
yeah yeah and they they even have me
talking about you know
positive things intensity integrity
intelligence and
uh you know using the three eyes and
doing your best yeah and it worked
because people were like
who is this guy what the hell is he
talking about like
i want to throw up right now so
he made me annoying as [ __ ] yeah and it
worked extremely well yeah i mean i get
fans today that say i hated your guys
but you know what i i appreciate it now
because yeah i didn't know you were
actually you know acting you were being
an [ __ ] yeah but um it was it was i
heard you like the first time you you
you went to pittsburgh people were like
booing you and [ __ ] yeah well vince said
listen you're gonna be a hill tonight i
said this is my first night on the air
and i'm in pittsburgh i said they're
gonna love me yeah he said no
you watch just say this and watch what
happens yeah and they did they [ __ ] on
me man it was yeah
vince was right it worked the wwe
audience uh you have to earn your keep
in order to be a big star there yeah you
don't just come in even if you're though
they don't look at you and say oh my god
olympic gold medalist is coming in i'm
so excited like they would in an nfl
draft yeah it's more like who's this guy
why do you think that is and
kurt come on in and dazzle us yeah we're
not going to be impressed unless you
impress us yeah so
they're they they have very high
expectations yeah and you have to meet
those those expectations whether you
want to be a bad guy or a good guy yeah
they're they're very hard on their on
the wrestlers yeah are there politics
they're going oh yeah there's a lot of
politics uh i think it's politics and
everything so
um
that's one thing i didn't like about
wrestling you know there there were
you know
the things you have to do and things
you're not supposed to do and you know
you have to follow that guideline and
it's unwritten rules but i think i think
it's in everything when you were
wrestling in college
what did what did like kurt
like what what
i watched you win the olympics in 96 and
john told me yeah and so
you know and i met you not too long
after that and then um
and so i mean it was a huge inspiration
you know it's it was right before my
senior year at george mason
and uh i remember watching you win man i
was just kind of you guys had a good
program man yeah yeah we're pretty good
uh johnny curtis came out of there he
used to wrestle open fox catcher johnny
quite a bit yeah man and he he used to
come back and tell stories of those fox
catcher days about john du pont and all
that stuff and we we heard stories about
i mean not to bring that up man but it's
well you you were there for a bit and
you left right yeah well i i i would
come and go i was uh i was a regular i
would be there about five to six months
a year and then i would train somewhere
else travel around the world but you
were younger yeah you were there yeah
yeah i was i was there geez
i'd say from 89 to 96 seven years yeah
and that was a huge honor to get invited
there oh it was the best club in the
whole entire world yeah yeah we had
everything and how weird was that
[ __ ] guy
i had
you know it's it's it's it's such a
tough thing because
you you want to say
he he did so much for the sport of
wrestling and if he didn't come in when
he did
uh we wouldn't have
ended up being number one in the world
we had the best team in the world it was
the first time ever
96 is the first olympic team that we
actually
as a team over one won the overall
points and how many of those guys were
fox catcher guys gosh a lot of them uh
yeah kevin
jackson the brands brothers
uh
me
uh geez uh
there are a bunch of them and um
uh
it's just uh you know john
john was doing some crazy stuff i know
he was doing drugs and
you know he he did some
one time i was in his house and he came
in and
uh you know he said you guys want some
pizza i said yeah yeah we're hanging out
we're in his mansion watching
tv in his trophy room and
he leaves the room for about 10 minutes
comes back and he's got white stuff on
his nose and he's doing this
he's like you guys have to leave and i
was like oh my god
so i go i go to leave and there's a guy
named robbie calabrese he's with me he
said no you stay here
and john pulls out a gun
and says uh
somebody's trying to get me i found
these uh tunnels in the basement he had
the world war ii or the civil war
the duponts they had these caves the
escape routes you know
so he he made rob go in there they're
only four feet high and he made him go
in and walk and john dupont went in
behind him he had the gun loaded and he
had to point it out
it was 600 yards
he had a gun loaded gun pointing his ass
he could could have died that day wow
but john did this crazy stuff all the
time he drove his car into a lake twice
pretending that he was a
balkan airlines pilot bulgarian airlines
he was obsessed with bulgaria uh the guy
he gave his his fortune to yeah was
valentine jordanoff bulgarian the
olympic gold medalist wow gave all his
money 450 million dollars to
jordanoff
um he was just obsessed with bulgaria
and uh
he he did some crazy [ __ ] but uh nobody
thought he was gonna kill anything i
think everybody just pretty much like
everybody just kind of like were wrote
him off as like ah it's just john b and
john he would fire his gun in the air
and stuff like that right near the end
we're all guilty of
let's keep this quiet until the olympics
and then everybody jumps up because what
he's offering you guys is what he's
offering
money uh facility
travel
uh the best training in the world
bringing the best coaches in
uh we had everything doctors trainers
we we had a we had a computer that would
teach you how to beat your opponent
we had so much stuff there
it was an incredible facility it was
right on his farm on where the mansion
was
and uh he had like 25 houses on the farm
so we all lived in houses
there was not a better facility yeah so
he had the best club in the world and we
wouldn't have been the best in the world
if it weren't for him and it sucks
because
he took away my my the one wrestler that
taught me more than anything dave
schultz he was my coach and uh
he took him away from me six months
before the olympics but dave taught me
enough
that i knew what to do for me thereon
you know i knew how to
take care of myself and get myself ready
but um
you know we're all a little bit guilty
of knowing that john was maybe capable
of doing something like that and we all
just want to keep it our lips shut to
even dave schultz said that he said when
when after the olympics were gone yeah
and uh
it did it was just happening there's
just something there's just something
not right something not right yeah we it
was time to go and unfortunately
john killed him six months before the
olympics so
it was really sad did you think that did
you think that the movie did a good job
like did did that seem yeah yeah i i
didn't like the way uh john's mom wasn't
alive
he waited for his mom to pass away
before he started the club because she
wouldn't approve of it it was too much
of a barbaric sport for
her son to be involved so john waited
till she passed away right but other
than that the movie was
the actors did incredible right now
what's the biggest misconception would
you say uh of of pro wrestling well i
think if you want to get into pro
wrestling you have to have a great
imagination i think that you
as a kid you you had to pretend that you
were
you know i used to when i was younger i
used this is crazy but
i would pretend that russia was spying
on me because i was such a superior
athlete and
they were watching me play basketball
and watch me play football and i like i
had this imagination
of you know
that i was this
incredible athlete that everybody in the
world was
you know searching for yeah wayne
you know
i was the next big thing you know so
um having the imagination
and being a great athlete and
intertwining those
can really help you in the wwe in sports
entertainment you also have to have some
acting skills too yeah you i mean you
it comes you know it comes with
experience you're gonna they didn't
teach me how to uh do that stuff they
they just said hey
you're you know we don't have they
didn't have a program back then for it
they had this dojo where they story funk
dojo where they taught you how to
wrestle and they did a little bit on
promos but it wasn't it wasn't a lot now
they have a nxt which is a training
facility they do promos they teach you
acting skills they teach you wrestling
everything back then they didn't have it
so when i started vince said
sink or swim here's your promo he
actually the first night he read it to
me he said you're going to say it and i
said vince i didn't hear a word you said
i'm a little nervous right now he goes
i'm going to tell you one more time
if you don't say it
you sink
so he told me one more time and he said
now go out and do it and i did it and
that's when he said i have somebody that
somebody special then what did you find
in me the about like the performance
aspect of it did that bring you towards
it or did it push it like
i loved it yeah i loved that because
you're [ __ ] great at it right yeah
yeah it was it was i didn't think i'd
pick up that quickly i
uh you know from when i started the
first day i wrestled or i learned
taking bumps i guess
uh two days later i had my first match
that's impossible that you know that was
i was very i picked up very quickly on
the technique
but
i they started me on tv literally seven
months later you usually have to be
about three to five years in before you
start on tv
uh seven months in and i won the world
title yeah ten months after that is it
yeah isn't this the 20-year anniversary
of you yeah yeah yeah so um
the thing is i i didn't know what i was
doing but dwayne the rock uh
called the whole match in there he just
told me where to go what to do
so here i am i'm going to be the
champion of wwe and i don't even know
how to work yeah right so
um but vince
i wasn't screwing up i was getting
better and better and better the more i
performed the more better i got the more
promos i did the better i got
and by the time i won the world title
there was no looking back yeah yeah and
then
being a great follower made me a great
leader and i learned how to work myself
and improvise and
before i knew it my next opponent was
stone quote steve austin i beat him for
the title yeah so the two biggest you
know two most popular support superstars
in history were my first two titles wow
and uh
it was a blessing because they taught me
so much that i became a great worker
after that and i started leading the
matches yeah yeah have you seen the
state of
of sort of the fans has it changed cause
i remember as a kid i used to go all the
time and i remember you know like my old
man used to take me and dougie when we
were kids and i mean like
i mean that it was like vulgar back then
man i mean people were like throwing
bottles into the ring
i mean the things that people were
saying i remember being like you know
first time like being really scared like
you know what i mean
of the audience stuff right but you know
i've gone to see you a a a a few times
and you know man i was actually really
surprised with how civil it's very much
they had to change it and a lot of it
had to do with um
wwe becoming a publicly traded company
um
uh once they did that the the
shareholders decided
how do we make the most money
kids
how do we get kids there
parents
how do we get the parents there
market to the kids so everything
merchandise
everything they do
um everything's pg-rated now yeah if not
even g-rated yeah you can't swear you
can't you can't say anything
uh that isn't approved so
they they they're making more money now
and
i'm not gonna say they have a bigger fan
base yeah they do worldwide but in the
united states the attitude era was
pretty much yeah you know the the main
era where we were selling out every
single night do you think it would have
been easier for you to play a heel or or
like a hit like a good guy
well i think uh starting out
the the problem with wrestling is pro
wrestling is
in order to be a baby face be a big baby
fish
you have to be a heel first
the fans won't accept you until you go
through the process yeah earning your
keep before you go so
whether you like it or not you have to
do it yeah um
i enjoyed it i liked people pissing
people off i thought it was fun yeah you
know
um
and
you know i you know
every once while i get something thrown
at me or you know you know it was
back then it was still a little rough
yeah but
i i it was cool i mean i i just really
enjoyed
uh pissing off the fans and
and having that reaction because i knew
that the more popular i became as a heel
the more popular i would be as an
overall wrestler so roddy piper didn't
become the biggest babyface in wrestling
good guy
uh because you know he just showed up he
did it because he earned it
he all those years he was healed these
fans you know
not only did they [ __ ] on him but they
were like
this guy this guy's entertainment he's
entertaining he's really funny there's
something about making people hate you i
mean i remember when i did shane on the
walking dead yeah you know like i had
never had any exp experience like that i
remember we went to like
you know new york comic con and the show
hadn't even come out yet
and you know like andrew lincoln that
was a good heel part by the way it was
so much fun man and i but i didn't even
like to me and i'm such a douchebag
actor i'm like i'm just playing the
integrity of you know he's a great guy i
feel like he's like i feel great you
know what i mean like i feel like he
made the right choices according to him
like i believe in everything that i'm
doing and like i remember at new york
comic con you know room of thousands you
know it was like walking dead this big
comic book and
andrew lincoln comes up and he goes
hello i'm andrew lincoln and i'm going
to be playing red cross and then like
sarah wayne college yeah i'm going to
play and they went like one by one and
then i came to me and i'm like hello
everybody i'm john bernthal i'll be
playing shane walsh and i was like ready
for the and it was like this resounding
like
and i was i remember i i was like oh you
know like me
yeah i was like what is this man like
you haven't even seen the show like i
like you know what i mean and i'm like
you and and it was uh
i it was i never i'd never felt that
before i mean you've been like to have a
uh thousands of people especially when
you're not expecting well i wasn't
expecting i was like how could you
applaud for her and not uh not like what
the [ __ ] are you basing this album but
you know man they their smart audience
and they read the comic books and they
hate they hated that character so shane
was always the heel he was always a
human and i fought and but the one thing
that i will say that's that's
interesting about it that that that goes
along right with what you're saying is
by the next year
once the show had already come out you
know and then shane had actually done
some bad you know he like killed he
killed the you know fat otis and he you
know you've done some pretty shady [ __ ]
yeah at that year when they announced it
they all were like yeah yeah you know
man they're like you might be shitty but
you are [ __ ] you know and i think we
accepted you yeah dude like you did it
all right man and and that like you know
man that that uh that definitely that
definitely made me happy and what about
like um you know obviously
you you know
the the the injuries that you yeah
that's what i'm wondering is how i mean
it's gotta be
so hard on your body to just sustain
all those shots over the years over
years over years yeah i i you know
amateur wrestling is one of the most
century-prone sports and i got injured a
lot doing it but um getting into pro
wrestling i didn't realize the wear and
tear put on your body i i
i thought it was fake i thought you know
all this stuff you know you were pulling
punches you weren't really
doing anything but you know when i got
there and i took the bumps you ever been
in the ring and take a bump
you have to be a supreme athlete right
yeah well it's just it hurts it's the
worst pain
um
you ever get you ever get hit from
behind going 50. yeah
it's pretty much what it is wow so you
have to yeah every every night too every
night you're bumping yeah and this is
what i tell young wrestlers that they
want to be will be superstars someday
which is great um
limit your bounce like you only have so
many in your career
and then that's what do you consider a
bum um that's when you uh
if someone slams you and you land on the
what do you call it it's wood basically
so how do you limit your bunk plywood
yeah how do you limit your bumps i mean
it's amazing um it's just a choice when
you start training they usually like
when when i did the dori funk dojo we
had to do 300 a day
you don't need to do 300 you need to do
about 10 15. yeah 300 is ridiculous like
so we're you know how many times did you
i mean what injuries did you walk into
the w had a broken neck i yeah i came in
i had uh four knee surgeries a broken
neck um
i broke my arm broke my shoulder but
when i got to the lab i broke my neck
four more times four more times
one was a chair shot to the head one was
uh
uh brock lesnar i was on his back and he
ran full speed and
he uh turned sideways and we hit the
turnbuckle my head snapped sideways and
it broke
and uh did you know immediately yeah my
whole right side couldn't lift my arm it
was just how do you continue at that
point ah you just use the other arm okay
that's all you can yeah yeah
but um makes sense you're john's pumping
you you get through the match i you know
i saw triple h once he tore his quad and
rolled up his leg and
he finished the match without a
quad the whole thing was rolled up so
you figure out a way i mean
but um
those injuries come a lot and the the
problem is you're wrestling 300 days a
year so
you don't have any time off yeah so you
wrestle injured you wrestle not injured
it doesn't matter guys must have a good
training staff too right uh they didn't
they do now thank god back then we we
were lucky to have a trainer there or
yeah it was what would you guys do just
take care of ourselves and uh i just
abused my body and i i stopped taking
care of it i didn't even stretch anymore
i'd literally go like this
go out and wrestle and
i was asking too much for my body for so
many years yeah yeah yeah and then and
and in your head you're just saying [ __ ]
it man this is this is work oh dude you
know and that's like and you know when i
was taking painkillers it just it was
always hurt here it just pops up
how quickly does that become out of
control and and when when do you realize
it i mean take me just a bit through
that process it got out of control right
away first time i tried a painkiller um
it was the greatest feeling in the world
i
i i felt invincible what was that was it
an oxy or uh it was extra strength
vicodin
and that was my drug of choice um
and i
you know once i got that feeling
i didn't ever not want to feel like that
again i wanted to have that feeling all
the time
so
when i when the when it would run out i
take another one and when it would run
out i take two then two random four you
build a tolerance yeah i was uh at one
point i was taking 65 extra straight
viking a day [ __ ]
and i was i was
feeding that addiction uh spending a lot
of money doing it but
you know i
i got myself in so much trouble
that there was no way i could get myself
out you know like uh at one point the
company wanted me to take time off and
get myself
uh clean
and i
i tried but i just couldn't do it it was
you know i
i needed assistance yeah so eventually i
went right and uh
got it done i haven't taken the
painkiller since but it's been seven and
a half years
but um it was it was uh
i mean there were a few times where i i
you know i should have should have been
dead i overdosed and
i was i was playing with fire that's
that's why i left the company in 2006. i
had to get out
i uh you know the painkiller problem was
ridiculous
uh the injuries
uh i wasn't getting any time off so it
was i just knew i if i didn't back out
then i was gonna i was gonna kill myself
you're in such a great place now but
would you be able to be in this place
that you're in now if you hadn't gone
through that like is it
no no i think i think it made me a
better person uh you know you know what
i still do now that i think i would have
probably once i retired from wrestling i
probably would just said
i'm good uh you know let's retire and
live the rest of my life
but going through the painkiller thing
and
ruining my reputation and you know uh
you know having people not call me
anymore
i had to
i had to earn that back i had to get i
had to work twice as hard to get back to
where i am now
and you know
we're a different breed you know we
we here we are 40s 50s
and we're still thinking of the goals we
want to attain
most people
you know they're they're good yeah you
know looking to settle down yeah you've
got to have a different
frame of mind to be the
the i don't want to say the elite that
think that way all the time but that
always want to improve themselves
and um i continue to do that and i think
that that my painkiller addiction
brought me back to that yeah and said
you know what your life's not over
that's right you're 51 you're just
beginning [ __ ] you
now it's time to start your new career
and now is the time to show the world
what you had then and what you have now
that's right that's right you know the
opioid crisis and like given where
you know western pennsylvania uh you
know it's interesting
it's just all over the place right and i
know it's i mean look man it's it's it's
hit our family
you know in a major way
and it's it yeah we got a bunch of
addicts you know but i mean it's it's um
i guess i'm just interested in why you
think
that crisis has has hit
has hit
the area that you grew up in i mean like
being married to aaron i mean i
there was a period of time where i like
i really felt like every time she was
getting a phone call from home it was
about some
tragedy whether it was in the family or
somewhere else or you know somebody that
she had grown up with or gone to high
school who od'd and died right you know
i i would definitely say that
my family has had been hit one of the
hardest with you know
drug addiction alcoholism my my father
was an alcoholic um
very functional
but he was he was always drinking all
day all night all day all night every
yeah and uh
you know
just being from a family like that and
seeing all the turmoil and pain
seeing people die seeing people go to
jail um
you know seeing your father die at a
young age of 55
it's it carries with you you know and
i never thought in a million years i'd
ever get trapped in it yeah i look at
your life now i look at your wife i look
at your family your career like you know
you're just like in this like beautiful
place um
i don't know man like what is it what
does that take
it's a lot of work um
you got to have the mindset of um
being able to turn things off and turn
things on in a flip of a switch so
my motivation is when when i think about
my wife and kids
i i know i'll stay clean
so as long as i have them up here
and in here i'll be fine uh the second i
ever think i'm gonna lose them
i would start worrying yeah so when i
went into rehab in 2013 i made it a
point
to get clean for them
not for myself because i told you before
i don't exactly love myself that much i
got pretty low self-esteem i've been
really hard on myself but i'm learning
how to
accept myself and love myself
and i think the more i do that
the easier it will get for me
but right now my motivation is not me
it's my wife and kids and that's what's
going to keep me clean i i think the
problem here again is there's so much
signaling there's so much saying hey i'm
i'm tough i'm trying we know i mean look
man professional fighter college
wrestler you olympic champion
world champion you know i play tough
guys on tv
we know the guy who sits there and and
and said talks about how tough they are
is masking something and the key to
you know immediately the guy who's
humble and the guy you know you always
say he's the best guy in the boxing gym
is the last guy you got to worry about
and i've seen sean beat the living snot
out of p he's the most humble guy in the
boxing gym but i've seen him beat
people's ass only because they came to
the gym being like i'll fight anybody in
here i'm like i'll fight you you know
with the huge shit-eating grin and like
any you know like i'd be glad to not
afraid are you i mean hey look man you
know and you know you you've had your
ass beaten yeah you know anybody that
you know claims they haven't you know uh
they haven't fought enough people that's
right you know right about that and
that's you know but you haven't gotten
your ass kicked yeah yeah and you
haven't fallen off you haven't fought
enough people yet but i think it's true
with life too and i think it's like a
beautiful metaphor that is and and and
again i think that you know when you
when you talk about just the the
political climate and the social climate
and you know everybody's kind of putting
all this [ __ ] out through social media
and politics is all about hey am i on
this side or am i on this side
i think
you know again it's ins
instead of exhibiting real power and
real strength with i think comes from
saying hey i'm human i'm just like you
i'm worried about [ __ ] things aren't
great for me either i'm trying to get
i'm trying to do the best i love my kids
i love my family i'm hoping for the best
i wish that there was more kind of
discourse like i
i wish more people knew that that that
people of our status feel the same way
as them that's right and that you know
we figure out a way to get through it
and we continue on and we try to have
great lives and happy lives and there's
a lot of people that just don't think
they have any hope so is that what it is
i mean when you when you look at the the
people who are kind of um you know right
now i mean like when you look at the
people western pennsylvania is it a lack
of hope is it what is the biggest
problem right now
you know
well the whole virus thing didn't help
any matters but pittsburgh is uh is a
lower middle class city that you know a
lot of people are struggling they're
very hard workers
and they they do whatever they can to
make a living
but i just you know a lot of them are
struggling and they're going through a
lot of stress it's the way it's the way
that they can reduce that stress or
taking drugs and
uh once once they're in it they it's
hard to get out you know
i don't think anybody goes in with the
intention of hey i want to be an addict
right let's do this right i think they
say
i want to forget tonight
just let me forget tonight
and then that becomes a habit every day
and every day you're having a bad day
you're like i just want to forget today
too and i want to fit
and it you know then before you know
you're just
you're stuck yep yeah what is one
story about my father-in-law that you
think like what is the mo like what is
one story that i've never heard i'll
tell you i think
i know there was like one that was like
maybe like time he got like stabbed up
and got put in that car or something oh
what's the most
like his lore all right what is this oh
well the one where he got stabbed he he
actually fought five guys and one of
them stuck a knife
uh one of them mark grabbed in the
double leg and got him up in the air and
his his arm came down and got him in the
uh
intestines yeah that's what his
intestines were popping out like he was
he was gonna die
thank god that there was a uh
basically what happened was uh my
brother-in-law my sister married him and
the these guys were accusing him of
robbing a house and my brother mark came
and said what's going on and they said
we're going to kill this guy because
he's he robbed a house or whatever mark
said no you're not
and they said what are you going to do
about it and they got in a fight
so five of them there were five of them
which you know i i thought was [ __ ]
but i talked to my sister and she
wouldn't lie to me
so she's telling the truth but he
he he beat up all of them yeah and the
last one got a knife in on him and
um
those intestines were coming out so
someone did the smart thing and rolled
him up in a ball
and then they threw him in the back of a
volkswagen if he wouldn't have done that
he would have died
so uh growing up i used to hear all
these rumors about him fighting and i
find out it was all true these
these high schools you know back then
gangs were you know
less
they didn't kill each other they just
beat each other up yeah back then there
was less killings
and uh they would travel to my brother's
high school and say
i heard your mark angle and i heard
you're the toughest
dude in pittsburgh and i want to try you
and they would and mark never lost never
lost
he was
you know everybody has a family member
you don't have a family member like this
this is different yeah
you know i want to go mount the olympics
and i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's just
he's in a different level and and uh
same with my brother eric mark and
eric's right under there but uh they're
two different breeds that
i i have [ __ ] with eric and i've paid
the price many times
and that's one thing
if you're gonna fight them this is where
you lose regardless because i thought
you know with my brother mark at one
point we got in a argument i was like
[ __ ] dad i'm i'm you know i'm 30 years
old he's 20 years old me i'm he's a
[ __ ] old man i'll kill him
i'm thinking if i do fight him i'm gonna
lose an eye
two fingers
so is is it gonna matter i'm gonna lose
anyway you know so mark's gonna do that
so he's you know he's gonna bite your
nose off he's gonna take your ears off
yeah so it's not worth it
no no honestly he would have kicked my
ass anyway but what i'm saying is even
if i could kick his ass i would lose
yeah it's not worth it yeah you know
yeah same with eric eric you'll bite
your hair off yeah yeah well it goes to
show why you became a world champion
don't mess with my brothers
i didn't have a choice yeah yeah
i mean you got to remember man you know
like i met aaron she's she's a first of
all i'm not earning any money man i'm
out of work
someone
i mean i'm doing plays sometimes where
there's like four people on stage two in
the audience i mean things are not
looking good i mean this like angel
beautiful you know i see you traumatized
yeah man she's paying for every meal you
know and she's like hey dad i you know
you got a great career yeah you wouldn't
believe who i met this freaking actor
yeah you know what i mean this actor
like gets in trouble and all the time
like you know like what a [ __ ] bag and
he you know and i'll tell you man now
he's i mean
you know i cannot i cannot imagine
having a better improvement friendship
you know with my father-in-law like i
love him i love all you guys man he's
not easy to get along with you he no man
he's not no i got he's he's uh he's very
did a good job
well i mean look man i you know i love
you man and i appreciate you doing this
and and uh it was an honor to be on oh
come on man we're gonna miss this in the
world right on man and it's great
it's a pleasure meeting you man
thank you glad to see you doing well too
oh thanks man appreciate it
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff uh it'd mean a lot to
us i hope you dig these episodes as much
as we dig doing them you guys take care
of yourself